AMEER ABBAS: I work with a
lot of enterprise customers.
And the biggest question
I get from them is--
How does Google do it?
How does Google build
globally scalable services
that for the most part stay up?
Things like Search,
YouTube, Maps Gmail.
So today I thought
what I would do
is I would actually take
you behind the curtain.
And let's take a peek at
what that platform looks
like from the eyes
of a service mesh.
We've all heard things like
Istio and Anthos Service Mesh.
But what do they mean?
And how do I build globally
scalable services with that?
My name is Ameer Abbas.
I'm a solutions architect
out of San Francisco.
And I focus on
distributed platforms,
specifically with
service mesh in mind.
So this is kind of what
we're going to talk about.
We're going to really
talk about what
does your application actually
need and what kind of choices
they have when it
comes to putting
your application on a platform.
We're going to talk about
multiple Kubernetes clusters
and what does that mean
for distributed services.
So most of us are getting into
the world of containerization.
And containerization
and Kubernetes
are kind of synonymous.
So I'm going to take that
one step further and talk
about multiple
Kubernetes clusters.
Then we're going to take a
step back and really look
at why service meshes exist.
Then we're going to look
at the actual service mesh
implementation with Istio
and Anthos Service Mesh
and how they actually perform
and what they actually do.
And then we'll bring
all of these concepts
together and build a platform
that can run globally
scalable, resilient services.
So let's get started.
Let's start with an application.
Typically, we think of
from a very infrastructure,
platforming point of view.
We think of-- What
does the platform need?
I want to flip that model,
and let's talk about--
What do applications need?
And applications have
a lot of choices.
Just in GCP, we have these
three main compute choices.
On the far left-hand
side, you've
got platform as a
service with App Engine.
This is a very opinionated
system that you use.
On the other end
of the spectrum,
you've got Compute Engine.
This is infrastructure
as a service.
It doesn't give you
anything, but it gives you
a lot of flexibility.
You have to build the
entire platform yourselves.
Both of these are very extreme.
On one side, you're
very opinionated, can't
bring in any of the
opinions that you'd like.
On the other side, you're
maybe too unopinionated,
and you have to
do all of the work
and all of the operations
and management yourself.
But then along comes
Kubernetes, and it gives us
a really nice middle point.
It gives us that
automation and abstraction
away from infrastructure.
And it gives us that declarative
way of deploying applications.
So, great, let's deploy our
applications on Kubernetes.
But what we've learned
is that you typically
don't deploy the applications
right on Kubernetes.
Kubernetes is a great scheduler.
It's a great container
orchestration solution.
But it doesn't give
you everything.
You need to still
build a platform
on top of Kubernetes-- things
like observability and security
and software delivery.
That all needs to happen
up top of Kubernetes.
So all of those opinions
that you bring in kind of
puts you in the middle of
this very opinionated path.
And somewhere in
there's Kubernetes.
And this is the arrow.
Where that arrow
sits is what we're
going to talk about
today is where that is.
Let's talk about Kubernetes.
So most of us have
at least started
to take the journey into
Kubernetes with container
orchestration and stuff.
So why do we need
multiple clusters?
Well, since we're talking
about building globally
scalable services,
by definition,
we're talking about multiple
locations or multiple regions.
A Kubernetes cluster can only
reside in a single region.
So if you're in two
or more regions,
you're already in
multiple cluster land.
Now, within a region,
when I talk to customers,
they talk about, "Well,
how do I make my services
resilient within a region?"
One way to do that is to
have multiple clusters
within a region.
Two is better than one.
One goes down, you
have something else.
So we just focus on
those two aspects--
multiregionality, clusters
in different regions,
and regional resiliency,
multiple clusters
in a single region
that gives you that.
And this spawns this
idea of something
called a distributed service.
The challenge with
the Kubernetes service
is that Kubernetes
service's fate
is tethered to the fate of
the cluster that it runs on.
Now, a service is a
very important thing.
That's your revenue generator.
That's what makes you money.
A cluster is just a
piece of infrastructure
that just runs your platform.
It actually costs you money.
So tying those two, or
tethering those two,
together doesn't make sense.
Distributed service, at a very
simplistic definition, is--
How can I put the same
service on multiple Kubernetes
clusters?
That's what a
distributed service is.
It's a very, very
simple concept.
What it does is it abstracts
your service's lifecycle
from your cluster lifecycle.
If I'm running on
multiple clusters,
I can have clusters
going up and down,
and my services can remain up.
Visually, it would look
something like this.
So here, I'm
representing two regions.
On the left-hand
side, I have region 1.
On the right-hand
side, I have region 2.
And then we have multiple
clusters in each region.
So on the left-hand side,
we have two zonal clusters--
one in each zone A and zone
B. And on the right-hand side,
I have two zonal clusters.
And I have a single
distributed service running
on all these four clusters.
So not only do I
have this service
that spans multiple regions, but
it also spans multiple clusters
within a region.
So I'm getting scalability,
and I'm getting resiliency.
I want to plant that
idea because it opens up
a lot of extra knobs when you
think in terms of distributed
services.
Things like I have to look
at service level objectives
at a service layer, not at
individual workload running
on each of these clusters.
If I can provide my
users with the SLO
that I've promised
them, it doesn't
matter whether it's
running on four
clusters or a single cluster.
Capacity planning
becomes easier.
We've heard terms like
N plus 1 and N plus 2.
If N is the number of clusters
that I need to run and satisfy
the requirements for capacity
for a particular service,
then N plus 1 and N plus 2 is--
Can I withstand a single
failure or double failure?
So we typically think in terms
of N plus 1 and N plus 2.
You can't do that
with a single cluster.
Rollouts and rollbacks can be
done at a very granular level.
So instead of pushing out a
new version of your service
to a single cluster and
to every single cluster,
I may want to just push out that
new version to a single cluster
in one zone and just have a
subset of my users use it,
test it out, and
then roll it out
to every single other cluster.
Internally at
Google, we use terms
like draining and spilling.
And it sounds exactly
like what it means.
If a cluster is having
an issue, or if I
want to upgrade a cluster,
I can drain traffic away
from that workload running
on that particular cluster
and spill it to other clusters.
So I still haven't
taken my service down,
but I've now freed
up that cluster.
And I can do
whatever maintenance
or operations or upgrades
that I want on that cluster.
So you can see that when you
think in terms of distributed
services, a lot of these
resiliency and scalability
knobs just kind
of open up to you.
So I want to park that idea.
And let's switch to why
service meshes exist.
And then we'll bring
these two ideas together.
So for this, I'm going
to go back in time
and look at this
monolithic application
that we've heard so much about.
And what is a
monolithic application?
It's just a collection
of functions.
But the first thing is
a monolithic application
is not a bad thing.
It's actually a
very deterministic--
It's a very good thing.
When function A calls
function B, it always works.
And it always works in a
very deterministic way.
It's a function call.
I don't have to worry
about is the function
B going to respond or not.
It is going to respond.
And if it doesn't, I can
just look at the logs,
and it's usually the
problem is in the code.
And I can just go
ahead and fix that.
Then someone smart
comes along and says,
"We're going to
containerize everything."
And all that means
is I'm going to take
those individual
functions, and I'm
going to run them as
individual quantums of compute.
And that's what a container is.
It's just functions
running in containers.
So the first thing
we've done is introduce
this concept of a network.
Now, this is the crux of
why service meshes exist.
This is the bane
of the problem--
is that we've taken
a function call,
and we've converted that
into a network call.
So the first thing we need
is we need a different way
to connect these
two things together.
We need an interface
or an API for example.
Most languages come
with their own APIs.
Or you can use an open
source API library like GRPC
and stick that on.
And now you're good.
You've got your client stubs.
You've got your server stubs.
These things can
talk to each other.
Well, that's great.
We've kind of solved just
the connectivity problem.
What about security?
We've heard these terms
zero trust network.
At a very simplistic
term, all that means
is I'm not going to trust
any form of a network,
whether it's an
external internet
or whether it's an
internal intranet.
So, in traditional
terms, what we typically
do is we really fortify the
periphery of our networks
with very solid,
big iron firewalls.
And we make them
very, very strong.
So it's very hard to
penetrate those walls.
But as soon as
you're in, we just
implicitly trust
everything on our intranet.
As you get into the world of
containers and distributed
systems, we realize that
even within the network
we need an extra
layer of security.
And this is the
concept of zero trust
network, where it's we're not
going to trust any network.
Each container and
each service must
be able to identify itself.
And this ID becomes a
very important concept.
So that's the
first thing we need
is now every service must
have an identification,
must have some way to identify
itself to other services.
Now, if I'm a
developer, and let's say
I'm just starting into
the world of containers,
I would go in Google, Python,
or Go security libraries,
and I would get these
libraries that do this for me.
And I would just implement those
libraries as part of my code.
And now what I've gotten
is I have gotten things
like authentication.
I can authenticate myself to
other services-- maybe even
authorization.
Am I allowed to do certain
actions to other services?
And I can get things
like encryption.
Because we don't
trust the network,
we don't want to have open
communication between these two
things.
Now everything is encrypted.
It doesn't have to happen over
a VPN or over the same network.
The next thing we
need is this idea
that networks are not resilient.
Networks are very unreliable.
When networks go
down, what happens?
When container A
calls container B,
and container B doesn't
respond back immediately,
what do you do?
Do you retry?
How often do you retry?
When do you stop?
You can build that logic
inside of your code,
or you can get a network
resilience library.
Again, as a developer,
I would go on Google.
I would Google something.
I would get a library.
I would slap that
onto my container.
And great, now I've taken
care of these network
idiosyncrasies-- latency, fault
tolerance, things going down.
We'll talk about
circuit breaker shortly.
Since everything is
now in a network,
and networks are not
infinite resources,
we need to figure out how to
put network policies on things.
How often container
A call container B?
We don't want to
bog down container B
if container A is
just hammering this.
So we need to be able to
put some sort of rate limits
and quotas on a per service
level and maybe even granularly
on individual services.
So now I need some sort
of a network policy.
And then last but not
least is observability,
which is probably the biggest
and the most important thing
when it comes to
distributed systems--
What is happening
in my environment?
Previously, everything was
kind of hidden in the logs.
I could just look at
the logs in a monolith,
and I could see this
function has this error,
and this function
is not working.
But now I have--
Is the problem in the network?
Is the problem in a request?
Is the problem in the API?
Is the problem with security?
So I need to measure
a lot of things--
things like metrics,
network metrics,
things like distributed tracing.
Most of the time you're not just
talking about two containers.
You may be talking about
hundreds or thousands
of containers.
And a single
request can traverse
a lot of different services and
a lot of different containers.
And things like
topology, I just want
to see what my
topology looks like.
Which services are actually
talking to other services?
Now, if you put a box
around all of these features
that we need in the
middle, they all
exist, because you have
decided to take a monolith
and put those
things on a network.
These are not your
business logic.
These are not the things
that make you money.
And these are very network
functions oriented things.
This is something
you absolutely need.
You cannot live
without these things.
You have to have them somewhere.
What a service
mesh proposes is--
Why don't instead of
putting all of this logic
into every single container
and as part of libraries,
is there a way to separate
your business logic away
from those network functions?
And what that visually
would look like is
I want to take
this picture, and I
want to convert that into this.
I have my business logic
now abstracted away
from all of my
network functions--
my identity, my observability,
my policies, my authentication
and authorization.
Since we live in a
world of containers,
we can toss both of those
things in the container.
And in Kubernetes, we can put
multiple containers inside
of a Pod.
Now, this is called
a sidecar pattern,
where you have your
primary container--
that's your application
container that's running up--
and then you have
a sidecar container
that's providing
additional functionality
to that primary container.
And that sidecar
container suspiciously
looks like a network proxy,
because it's providing
a lot of network functions.
Envoy is a very
popular proxy that's
used in distributed system.
That's used for
client-side load balancing,
because now I'm going
to slap this Envoy proxy
to every single container.
There are a lot of operational
benefits to this too.
I have a very clear
lines of delineation
between roles and responsibility
on who's doing what.
Above this blue line
is my business logic
or my application developers.
They can just now focus on
developing the application.
Below this line
are my operators.
They can focus on
building the platform,
putting policies
on the platform,
and enforcing those policies.
This is to me the true
definition of portability.
This container now can
run anywhere as long
as those functions is
provided by the platform.
And now I've relegated these
additional network functions
onto the platform layer that
are managed by experts that
know how to manage networks,
how to manage security,
how to manage observability.
So let's look at an
implementation of this.
How do we implement this thing?
Istio and Anthos
Service Mesh are just
two of the implementation.
Istio is an open
source implementation
of a service mesh.
Anthos is a Google
managed service mesh
that uses the same APIs,
uses the Istio APIs.
And I'm going to build the
control plane and the data
plane at the same time.
And I'm really just going to
focus on the functionality,
because I think that's
the important bits.
And the implementation
is not as exciting.
So on the data plane,
we have a bunch of Pods
with the Envoy proxies
running on each Pod.
And then we have
this control plane.
And the first thing
we need to know
is that Istio and ASM needs
their own service registry,
which is nothing
more than just a list
of all the services that are
running in the service mesh
and all of the endpoints
on how I can get to it.
So these are the IP addresses
of each of the Pods.
These could also be the IP
addresses of each of the VMs.
And it doesn't matter where
these Pods are running.
They could be running
on a single cluster
or multiple clusters.
With this, I get additional
benefits of traffic management.
I can do very granular things.
For example, if I'm deploying
a new version of service B
or Pod B, which is Pod
B prime, and I only
want to send a subset
of the traffic there,
now I can do things like I just
want to send 10% of the traffic
to the new version and
90% of the traffic that
remains to my old version.
I can test out the new version.
Everything looks good.
And then I can slowly
ramp that new version up.
Observability, where previously
we talked about logging
was the only thing in the
monolith that was important.
And now we need network
observability, network metrics,
distributed tracing.
Because these Envoys are placed
in a very fortunate position,
they wrap up all
of these metrics.
And they emit those
in Prometheus specs.
And then you can send them
to any collector you'd like.
So with Istio and Anthos Service
Mesh and GC, automatically
we ingest them into cloud
monitoring, which is previously
known as Stackdriver.
But you can use any
collector you'd like.
Security was another thing
that we wanted to talk about.
It's a zero trust network.
We don't trust the intranet.
We want everything
to be encrypted.
These Envoys now are kind of
the holders of your identity.
And they hold a strong identity.
They hold certificates.
A certificate authority
with a shared common root
can now furnish the certificates
to each of these Envoys.
And on the basis of
that, they can now
authenticate to each
other, and they can also
do TLS and encryption
between each other.
Policy, not only
just network policy.
We talked about network
policy as, for example, Pod A
wants to talk to Pod
C, and maybe we've
limited that to only do
100 requests per second.
But authorization, role-based
access authorization too,
which is--
What can actually
Pod A do to Pod C.
So it can do a GET and a POST on
these particular API endpoints.
That can also be done through
Istio and through the Envoy
proxies.
And last but not
least is the platform
and the service resiliency.
A circuit breaker is a
common pattern that's
used in production per service.
So this is this idea that if
a service is having an issue,
we want to be able to fill that
service as quickly as possible
and take countermeasures
against it.
So let's say we have a flow that
goes from Pod A to B to C to D,
and D is having problems.
Instead of that
flow just continuing
to run and eventually just cause
backwards cascading failures,
we want D to quickly identify
that I'm having some issues.
And the other
services can then just
take countermeasures and
precautions on top of that.
So in this case,
let's say we put
a rule that says, "If I see
five consecutive HTTP errors,
just consider me down.
Go around me, and
do something else.
Notify the user.
Tell them to wait or back
off or any of these logics
that you can put in."
And fault injection
is something you
can do to test the resiliency
of your application.
So how would my application work
if I injected a 10% error rate,
or if I injected a
10 millisecond delay?
This is also something one of my
customers used to actually test
something where they
wanted to deploy it
into a different region that
was about 50 milliseconds away.
And instead of spinning up
an entire infrastructure
in that region, they just simply
injected a 50 millisecond delay
and just tested
and observed what
their services are going to do.
So these are the six
features and functionality
of the control plane that
are above and beyond what
Kubernetes gives you.
Service registry works
across multiple clusters.
Traffic management can happen
at a very granular service
per service level.
Observability gives
you extra things
without having to
instrument your thing.
You get security and
policy above and beyond
what Kubernetes gives you.
And then you get resiliency
on when Kubernetes
is having problems and
services are having problems,
how can I automatically recover
from those particular services?
So that's great.
So we have this distributed
services concept.
We have this concept
of a service mesh.
Let's build a platform together.
And let's build that on GCP.
So the first thing
I'm going to say
is that a lot of these
concepts can apply
on non-GCP environments too.
And we're only going to
build one environment.
So think of this as this is
my production environment,
and I'm about to onboard
a service or a product
in multiple regions.
And we're going to just pick
two regions, because if you
can do this in two regions, you
can do this in 20-plus regions.
So everything starts
with the network.
And what we want
to do is we want
to have a nice flat network.
It makes communication
between Pods
and between Pods and other
services much, much easier.
And we want to wrap that
around into a single network.
In Google, we have a concept
of a shared VPC that can
be shared to other projects.
So we have this one
project, project 0, that's
owned by your networking team.
And it gives them
centralized control.
So instead of giving every
single team their own network,
you have this one
centralized network.
They control the
ingress and egress
out of that particular network.
And it makes it much
easier for services
to communicate with one another.
Inside of that,
we have projects.
Now project in Google
is just a collection
of resources owned by a certain
team or by a certain function.
So in this case, we're just
representing two projects.
We have a platform_admin
project that's
owned by the platform
admins team, that's
your operator team.
And then we have this
product1 project that's
owned by a single product team.
And imagine if you
have multiple products,
then you would have project
3, project 4, and so on.
When I think of
projects, I think
of three levels of controls.
Billing is done at
a project level.
So anytime I want
separation of billing-- so
by environment, by
team, by function--
it's a good way to put a
project boundary around it.
Access management is
done at a project level.
So things that are
owned by let's say
the platform admins team should
belong into the platform admins
project.
And things that are
owned by the product team
should belong to the product.
And last but not least, quota
is done at a project level.
So where you don't want to share
quotas between different teams,
it's much easier to just put
a project boundary around it.
We also put environments
in separate projects.
So here I'm showing
a three-project setup
for let's say the
prod environment.
You would have a very similar
setup for dev and stage
as well.
Then inside of these
projects, we put subnets.
Subnets in GCP and
Google are regional.
And we recommend you use
as lowest number of subnets
as possible.
So here I'm representing
two regions.
On the left-hand side,
we have region 1.
On the right-hand
side, we have region 2.
And we have two subnets--
subnet 1 and subnet 2.
You can have more subnets.
But it's much easier to
expand a single subnet
than to have smaller subnets
where you didn't maybe
size them right the first way.
IPAM, IP address management,
becomes much easier.
You have to start
thinking about--
How many IPs do
I need for nodes?
I need for Pods--
which are the biggest
resource hogs for IPs--
and for service IPs?
We always recommend
using custom subnets,
so not having IP wastage, by
having these automated subnets.
Inside of those subnets, you
have your Kubernetes clusters.
Now these are your
Kubernetes clusters
that are there for applications
as well as for operations.
So in this case, we're
showing a six-cluster setup.
And they're both identical.
There's three clusters in region
1, three clusters in region 2.
If you want other
regions, you can
think about horizontally
scaling this out and basically
stamping this exact environment
in other regions as well.
We have these colorful
clusters-- the orange, red,
blue, and green.
Think of them as your
application clusters.
This is where your
actual services
that are used by other services
or used by your customers
are actually going to sit.
We'll call them apps clusters,
or application clusters.
Then you have these two
clusters at the bottom,
the gray clusters.
Think of them as your
operations clusters.
This is where your shared
services are going to sit.
This is things like CI/CD,
tooling, observability,
or, in this case, the ASM
or the Istio control plane.
By separating out your
applications cluster
and your operations
cluster, we've
kind of separated out
the lifecycle of the two.
We want to manage those
independently of one another.
Your applications probably will
have a much higher scrutiny
for SLOs and stuff.
And maybe they're not
being upgraded as often,
and we want to maybe
really take care of those.
As opposed to your
operations clusters,
which can go down for an
extended period of time.
And it may or should not
affect too many things.
So by separating those
two clusters out,
I have granular control
over how I upgrade
and how I maintain and
operate on these clusters.
We started with a single ASM
control plane per region.
We can put a control plane
in every single cluster.
That's a perfectly
viable design.
And if you have a small
number of clusters,
as a matter of fact, that
is what's recommended.
But then we realized that as
you grow-- as you go beyond
let's say 20, 30,
40, or 100 clusters--
then you would have
100 control planes,
and it becomes an operational
challenge and a nightmare
to manage those.
We also do a single
control plane per region.
This way you're not
dependent upon other regions
or regional connectivity
or even latency.
Within a region, your
latency is very, very small.
We put the control
plane in there
in the ops cluster
at the bottom.
And now you can just continue
to add application clusters.
And they all connect back to
that single control plane.
And we've already talked
about the separation
of lifecycle management
as well as ownership,
where your application clusters
and operation clusters could
be owned by different teams.
So now you have even though
it's logically a global mesh,
but you have these
regional meshes
that are in a shared
control plane module.
So you have a
single control plane
sharing all of the clusters
within that region.
But both of these control
planes have the full picture
of the entire infrastructure,
of every single cluster.
Then comes in namespaces.
Namespaces is a very
important concept when
it comes to service meshes.
In a globally
scalable service mesh,
in a single logical
global service mesh,
a namespace across
multiple clusters
is assumed to be the same thing.
So in this particular
case, if I create
a namespace called
product1-namespace
on four different clusters,
and I have workloads running
in these namespaces,
from the Istio service
registry or the Anthos Service
Mesh service registry's
perspective, it's considered
a single distributed service.
Aha, got that word back--
distributed service.
We're starting to
talk about that.
I'm getting regional
redundancy, because I
have multiple clusters
within that region.
I'm getting global
redundancy, because I'm
running the same service now
across multiple clusters.
I'm also utilizing
my clusters better,
because now I can create
namespaces as these landing
zones for my services.
I don't have to create
separate clusters
for individual services.
Namespaces are the landing zones
for, in this case, product 1.
And that's what I'm renting
out or I'm giving out
to that particular service.
If I have product 2,
product 3, product N,
those will all be
namespaces that
are placed on these
clusters, all part
of the single
global service mesh.
And service meshes can
talk to each other,
whether it's running in one
cluster or multiple clusters.
And since all of these
clusters are on a flat network,
I never leave my VPC.
Everything is done on the
same virtual private cloud.
So think of namespaces
and landing zones.
And think of multi-tenant
clusters always.
Multi-tenant clusters give
you the best resiliency.
So even in this example,
I've got a product 1 service
running on four clusters.
Technically, again, I can lose
three of these four clusters,
and I've never lost my service.
So I lose an entire region
and part of my other region,
and I have not lost it.
Versus if I had
individual clusters
that I'm not amortizing
between different services.
Now these product 1 services
can talk to other GCP resources
that are running in project 2
in that particular product team.
So this is a good way
to think about how
to manage multiple clusters
in multiple regions,
how to overlay a
service mesh on top,
how to think about
project hierarchy
as well as networking, how we
think about IAM and controls.
This, what we see, is a good
way to think about globally
scalable services.
And, by the way, this is
how Google builds services
internally.
If you want to learn more, and
if you want to build exactly
what I showed you, you
can go to the first link--
bit.ly/asm-workshop.
That will give you
actual terraform scripts
to build exactly
what we showed--
as well as you can learn about
how to deploy applications,
how to secure applications,
how to observe them, and so on.
And if you want to learn more
about multi-cluster lifecycle
management--
Well, now I'm going into six
or seven or eight clusters.
How do I upgrade those clusters?
And how do I manage and
operate multiple clusters?
You can learn more on
the blog series I wrote.
It's a five-part blog
series on the second link,
which is bit.ly/gke
multicluster lifecycle.
That shows you how to
upgrade one cluster
at a time and different
strategies of managing,
monitoring, and maintaining your
multiple cluster environment.
Thank you very much.